época seu trabalho ajudando famílias e
pequenas empresas a lidarem com o
dinheiro
diante disso trabalhava com computação
eu juro que daria pra contar a história
da minha transição profissional de um
jeito muito muito romântico e aparecer
que eu fiz um planejamento muito bem
feito e que não tinha dado certo mas a
verdade é que foi um processo
absolutamente caótico totalmente
controlado feito gastrite e mas quando
pára pra pensar em como esse projeto
aconteceu e como as coisas se
desenrolaram a cabo também feliz porque
fui obrigado a me deparar com o fato é
que atualmente acompanha todos os dias
com todos os meus clientes sabem o que
acontece com você também um planejamento
falho e tudo bem e não é por conta disso
e eles deixam de ser úteis
insatisfeito com a vida profissional e
eu fiz o que todos os jovens da minha
geração fazem quando eles não têm
grandes problemas na vida e nem muitas
bocas para alimentar
eu me cadastrei todos os pedestres sobre
pela frente
basicamente isso que eu fiz e foi uma
decisão muito acertada
eu conheci muita gente interessante a
gente que levava vida de um jeito muito
diferente do que estava acostumado
em um certo ponto eu comecei a
vislumbrar a possibilidade de trabalhar
com outra coisa
por algum motivo trabalhar com
consultoria financeira me parecia uma
decisão o que eu tinha facilidade com
números eu gostava de lidar com
problemas e com pessoas
eu comecei a contar com alguns amigos
dessa minha decisão de um dia começou a
trabalhar com o conselho financeira e
esses amigos conversaram sobre isso com
outros amigos e quando fui ver eu estava
acompanhando a vida financeira de 67
cobaias e se dispunham a me escutava a
coisa funcionava e eu tentava
basicamente aplicar com eles coisas já
estavam funcionando na minha vida
financeira pessoal e quando fui ver eu
comecei aprofundar a coisa
porque a proporção que comecei a
escrever sobre isso na internet e de
repente eu estava às vésperas da minha
primeira consultoria com um cara que não
era meu amigo e nem era amigo nenhum
amigo meu e eu estava apavorado e eu fui
buscar ajuda
vou conversar com alguns psicólogos e
buscar conselhos que recebi vários
conselhos muito bons
sobre como atender pessoas
individualmente e um conselho que marcou
muito foi limite o seu tempo de
atendimento
então se você está se propondo a atender
por uma hora apenas por uma hora enfim
eu fiz na cabeça eu falar numa segunda
feira às duas da tarde de frente com o
advogado no starbucks pedir licença o
meu chefe me deu uma desculpa e falar
bem desse cara e ele era muito mais
extrovertido que eu muito mais velho que
eu e absurdamente mais eloqüente que eu
e aí eu fiz uma pergunta qualquer
querendo começar uma conversa
esse cara começou a falar às duas de 11
e foi parar de falar às 3 horas e eu não
tive a minha mobilidade interromper esse
cara e eu saí de lá absolutamente
frustrado achando que iria ali como
consultor financeiro muito em breve e eu
posso repensar tudo e na noite desse
mesmo dia chegou um e mail pra mim esse
cara eu abri cheio de receio achando que
ele estaria dispensando e na verdade é
meio dele dizia a mulher em seu trabalho
incrível
eu tô eu estou super satisfeito e
ansioso pela próxima sessão e e eu
fiquei eu tivesse eu via os entrar em
desespero porque não tinha entendido
nada do que tinha acontecido ali fez em
agora na hora foi assustador e demorou
algum tempo para entender qual a
dinâmica tinha acontecido por trás
daquele teatro todo
na verdade isso acontecer de novo embora
os clientes é a vida financeira desse
cara com nova exatamente a mesma depois
da primeira sessão de consultoria a
gente a mexer em nada mas antes o que
ele sentia de verdade era uma culpa
absurda o seguinte incapaz de olhar o
extrato
eu acabei percebendo que incomoda a
gente de verdade não é bem a falta de
dinheiro
incomoda a gente de verdade é a sensação
de descontrole
muitas vezes a falta de dinheiro traz às
vezes a gente acha que é uma questão de
ganhar mais dinheiro e ter um salário
maior mas eu juro para vocês façam um
exercício pensa no primeiro salário de
vocês nos portos ganhámos 500 reais
iniciais segurava por deus
quando você ganha assim mil tudo ia ser
muito melhor que começou em abril
e aí você começa a pensar quando você
ganha r 2 mil a r sim estou mais em
dinheiro e você começou em 2000 e você
continua se preocupando com dinheiro
então não é bem uma questão de quando a
gente ganha é uma questão de ver como é
que a gente consegue enxergar os
problemas financeiros como é que a gente
consegue encaixar com o aspecto
financeiro na nossa vida e depois esse
cara eu acabei cruzando com vários
outros clientes e eu percebi é que a
nossa relação com o dinheiro a gente
acha que é racional mas é verdade uma
relação estritamente emocional
meu irmão chamado victor e por um bom
período da vida ele como gordo mais
preocupado com essa questão
e aí ficava sozinha tarde em casa minha
mãe chegava a noite perguntava e evitar
que você comeu e eu falava que tinha
comido uma bolachinha o vítor é um
amante do meu tamanho e ele tinha comido
um ou dois pacotes de bolacha
mas ele falava bolachinha por quê
enfrentar a realidade de que ele não tá
conseguindo decidir de maneira racional
sobre o que vai comer sobre o que faz
bem pra vida dele incomoda demais a
gente uma dificuldade muito grande de
lidar com essa sensação de assumir esse
descontrole
a nossa relação com o dinheiro é muito
parecida com elas não gastam com a
comida
tempos depois desse advogado eo
atendimento do estádio
e esse publicitário era viciado em
comprar roupas e ele começou a me contar
dos deslizes da semana e ele falava cara
essa semana eu comprei uma camiseta mas
não falava camiseta e falou que ela
tinha
mas também era um cara com uma barba
também da minha e ele falava a camisa
tinha e ele falava sapatinho ea gente
vai fazer piadas sobre isso até que
chegou um dia que o cara não sei nem o
que falar nesta semana sobre uma calça e
eu não vou te falar que eu comprei uma
calcinha e a coisa funciona e ficou cada
vez mais claro quando os clientes
chegando que na verdade é uma relação
estritamente emocional mesmo que não
adianta a gente achar que a gente vai
corrigir na planilha de excel que a
gente não vai eu comecei a ficar com a
agenda lotada me surgiu a idéia de
trabalhar com grupos e percebeu estava
cheio de receio porque eu ia colocar na
mesma sala 20 pessoas que não conheciam
que tinham renda diferentes para falar
sobre dinheiro mas elas não falar sobre
dinheiro de uma maneira abstrata
questionando como é que o homem encara a
questão da moeda e da escassez a gente
falar da nossa vida financeira prática
os nossos números eu resolvi lançar essa
proposta e ver o que vinha ea gente
abriu e quando eu falo a gente é porque
é um projeto faz parte de um outro
projeto maior chamado lugar eo agente
abriu as inscrições para essa turma e
lotou em 48 horas o trabalho em grupos
para mim foi muito interessante muito
incrível e me rendeu alguns insights que
eu provavelmente não teria se estivesse
trabalhando individualmente e vou
compartilhar alguns deles com vocês
o primeiro deles que coloco na minha
cara na primeira turma deste curso em
são paulo
o conhecimento técnico importa muito
pouco
às vezes a gente acha que a gente
precisa
um software um aplicativo de celular de
última geração que gera gráficos
tridimensionais para consolidar o nosso
dinheiro e eu fui percebendo é que o que
a gente precisa mesmo é de atenção e de
bom senso de vó é bom senso de voto é
aquele concelho e aquela coisa qualquer
pessoa poderia dar pra gente
num sei de ninguém e engravatado não
precisa de gerente do banco não precisa
do programa de educação financeira da
empresa ctt ó o que a gente precisa é
simplesmente de atenção e de bom senso
isso foi estampado na minha cara logo na
primeira turma quando uma menina falou
que a vida financeira dela se divide em
dois tipos de meses mesmo que ela tinha
consulta com o dermatologista e uma vez
que ela não tinha porque o mês que ela
tinha consulta com o dermatologista ela
estava a 600 reais no começo deste mês
depois por já ter gasto r 600 reais ela
mesmo sem canal do resto do mês
isso aí começou a se preocupar de novo
no próximo salário
e ela abriu esse problema na turma toda
e aí eu responder comentando alguns
aspectos psicológicos desse processo mas
um cara me interrompeu com o cara da
turma e era o cara mais simples a turma
era vendedor não tinha formação superior
e vergonha amigo que a gente acha que um
mês mas ele falou a moça mas é 600 reais
a consulta é muito sincero centrais ea
cada dois meses dois meses e aí ele fez
contra o dedo isso com muito claro pra
mim que tinha muita atenção e fez assim
e aí ele apresente porque senão guarda
300 reais por mês é um lugar
ele soltou esse comentário tão guardado
num envelope presente reais por mês
quando você for um dermatologista
valéria envelope e pessoal olhou pra mim
pra eu saber como é que eu jogaria essa
solução
no fim há na verdade essa solução do
envelope é genial
primeiro ela distribui o gasto todo em
meses pra gente poder ter uma rotina e
isso facilita muito a vida e o segundo
ponto muito importante é aquela força
gente a lidar com o papel
se vocês acham bobo a questão de lidar
com o dinheiro de papel faça um
exercício pensa na próxima compra 600
reais
vocês podem fazer é pegar dez notas de
10 a 49 50
três notas de cem e você vai na loja
você começa a dar suas notas para
vendedor e você vai dar notas de valores
diferentes para segmentar sofrimentos
diferentes você vai colocar dez reais 10
reais
eu duvido que você faria essa mesma
compra com essa mesma dificuldade se
fosse um cartão de débito ou de crédito
passando esse experimento e em helmand
conselho de voto porque eu lembro da
minha avó que nunca estudou economia e
nunca deve ter ouvido falar o conceito
formal de custo de oportunidade mas ela
sabia se ela não fizesse a feira no
sábado e comprar essas verduras a semana
ele tem que comprar na quitanda durante
a semana ea sair mais caro ea bobina é
tão fresca
então ela não precisou estudar é é uma
lei muito refinada para saber como é que
as coisas funcionavam a minha mãe a
pedagoga e provavelmente não estudou
economia profundamente mas ela sabia se
ela não alimentasse seu irmão antes
levar a gente para a praia a gente come
tudo tivesse em todas as barracas e ela
gastar um rio de dinheiro mas ela também
não sabe qual é o custo atrelado à
operação de elevadores favorita praia
ela não parou pra pensar nisso é o bom
senso
é isso que falta o segundo ponto ficou
muito claro para mim é que a gente tem
que falar sobre dinheiro ea gente fala
pouco muito pouco
a questão é que a nossa vida financeira
é um assunto mais velado do que a nossa
vida sexual
a gente fala que brocha mas não falta no
vermelho
e isso é muito verdade e rossi o
dinheiro é um negócio útil não
simplesmente porque eu gosto de falar
sobre dinheiro realmente gosta e eu
literalmente faço isso o dia inteiro mas
a verdade é que falar sobre dinheiro é
importante porque nunca é só falar sobre
dinheiro fala sobre dinheiro fala sobre
sonho é falar sobre medo é falar sobre
como a gente encarar a vida é falar
sobre como a gente encara os nossos
projetos e compartilhar coisas ea gente
tem um defeito ea gente acha que a gente
é muito muito especial e que os nossos
problemas financeiros são incríveis
já se passaram pouco mais de 70 clientes
nesses últimos quatro anos
eu tenho a dizer pra vocês é que a gente
sofre exatamente pelas mesmas coisas a
gente gosta de achar os nossos problemas
são muito exclusivos
mas a verdade é que nós somos todos
muito comuns e que a gente tem
exatamente os mesmos problemas
diferentes roupagens e já que os
problemas são coletivos já que a gente
só pelas mesmas coisas
não faz muito sentido de buscar a
solução sozinho então é seria muito
melhor se a gente conseguisse assumir de
uma vez que todo mundo sofre pela mesma
coisa
e seria muito melhor se a gente
conseguisse pegar emprestado os olhos eo
bom senso um dos outros
com certeza a gente sofria muito menos e
conseguir aliar o dinheiro a projetos
incríveis ea vida sem times produziram
coisas ainda mais em início de uma
arrancada isso muito obrigado